[Music]
one of the most famous costumes in
cinema is this plain white tank top
[Music]
worn by bruce willis in die hard but a
lot of the damage you see on it didn't
just happen naturally it was
deliberately faked by the film's costume
designer marilyn vance
tv dinner feels like today there's a job
specifically for aging and destroying
costumes as described in the plot
breakdown artists like sarah blasting
need an intimate understanding of the
scene and countless creative ways to
recreate all the damage a costume
endures
when done right they might just create
an iconic piece of cinema history that
ends up in the smithsonian
a lot of what we do
the breakdown is from use every piece of
clothing on a movie set requires some
sort of manipulation even a simple white
shirt gets bathed in dies or tea
but breakdown artists go far beyond that
like sarah's work on the boys
on set the gunshot impacts were created
by putting squibs under the actor's
jacket which left holes in the costume
but these tears looked nothing like real
bullet holes the problem with this is
that it causes the fabric to blow
outwards it would never do something
like this one way to tackle this is to
sew the holes up bullet hole actually
looks like a cigarette burn the size of
squib that they used made gigantic
bazooka size holes in her jacket so
offset the breakdown team made the
bullet holes from scratch using a craft
knife to guarantee the holes lined up
precisely breakdown artists can also
emphasize details that aren't
necessarily realistic but stand out on
camera there is a certain amount of
movie magic lying that you have to do
when you do create a bullet hole and
make it a bit more recognizable to the
audience like adding a little black
paint around the edges to mimic
gunpowder some people misinterpret this
look of bullet wipe and think that it's
actually gun powder you wouldn't get gun
powder residue on a shot unless the
muzzle was directly up against the
person
there are a number of tools you can use
to create smaller rips and tears from
fights
sarah's favorite tool
a steak knife but it's less easy to
control meaning less precision since
you'll have to make multiple identical
versions of the same outfit as backup
craft knives and seam rippers are better
for consistency when it came to the
strain she had to adjust for this
apocalyptic scenario so she needed tools
like a file
a rougher
and a wire brush for more destructive
tears
some outfits like this jacket from the
strain are made of materials that are
harder to rip
for this she'll have to use a cheese
grater i really only use this on things
that will not break down any other way
it's not only rips and tears there are a
bunch of different ways to represent
wounds and blood and sarah has to decide
what techniques work for the scene in
the boys the characters crash into a
whale the special effects team was
tasked with most of the blood and guts
on set but the breakdown team had to
cycle through several bloody outfits
their biggest challenge getting the
color of blood right to maintain
continuity when the characters first hit
the whale the blood stains are a
brighter shade of red as it dries it
appears much darker
but the breakdown team couldn't let the
fake blood dry on its own as they ended
up shooting the later scenes in the
episode first that meant separate shirts
for fresh and aged blood with the stains
lined up precisely sarah also had to
factor in the different ways blood
reacts to fabrics and other props the
only time blood would really
make drips like that
is on something that's plastic if it's
on fabric
it tends to run in sometimes i find it's
more realistic just to use your hands
for something like whale guts the
material matters as much as the color
for the fresher guts she needed
something chunky that would stick to
clothes and only look wet the silicone
will kind of form to whatever is
underneath so if you do it flat you're
going to have a flat
looking shirt which is why it's best to
use a mannequin it will
keep that kind of wet clingy fabric
look when we were doing this we'd start
with a brush or with a stick and then
just give up and use our hands
because honestly you're just smushing
stuff all over and
you don't really have to be artistic
about it
so there's a nice
gross piece up there
for the later scenes where the guts have
dried sarah switched to latex it still
had some shine and clung to the fabric
just like the blood when they're dried
they're darker they're kind of shriveled
up
blood and rips are pretty common
breakdown scenarios for action projects
but sometimes the scene will throw sarah
a less common situation like for this
scene in ready or not sarah had to think
about how clothes decompose on a body
she had to work on the tuxedo on this
corpse which had been buried underground
for decades
first the clothing had to reflect the
context so this guy gets
shot with a bow and arrow but he's
probably been running around before this
right so he might have some rips he
might have some dirt definitely some
sweat she used black paint for the
bloodstains as they'd fully dried out
and congealed then she had to think
about how the bodily changes would
impact the outfit
there's death there's bloating there's
liquefaction there's putrefaction
there's desiccation i really wanted it
to look like you know whatever body
juices seeped out into him seeped out
into his clothes this body was also
buried in a deep pit so sarah mimicked
the dry rot caused by moisture and added
holes from moths and other insects
that's really where the rougher and file
were useful
to top it all off because the corpse was
underground it was covered in dirt and
believe it or not recreating dirt is one
of the toughest challenges of the job
using real dirt is really unpredictable
as some dirt stains could be permanent a
problem in the event that productions do
need to wash and reuse an outfit
so sarah will replicate it with
non-permanent materials for the tuxedo
she painted on brown spots and ground up
non-permanent powder to create mud
stains
and for the boys sarah had to adjust
kenji's clothes after he brings down a
ceiling on homelander and later gets
thrown through a wall by stormfront
she went beyond dirt powder and added
diatomaceous earth a powder that
simulates the dust and dirt you'd find
in a tunnel
after kenji gets thrown through the
drywall sarah added the cellulose which
is the same material used for insulation
in houses
it matched the set debris perfectly
even the sweat stains you see on screen
can be fake this is especially true for
action scenes that are shot out of order
to simulate sweat stains that stick and
look wet she sprays a mix of glycerin
water and oils it won't just run
everywhere it'll kind of stay put where
it's supposed to be
none of these techniques we've mentioned
so far would work for these scenes and
the boys however because of the super
suits
these costumes were expensive and shift
from la to canada for the shoot so the
production team didn't have multiple
versions to mess around with so how did
stormfront and black noir suits look so
damaged here and here so we had to come
up with unique and innovative ways to
make the costumes look like they were
damaged without actually damaging them
sarah used leftover fabric to recreate
stormfront suit that way the breakdown
team could rip it and sew in prosthetic
burn wounds created by the makeup
department by painting a mushy mixture
around the edges of the rips sarah could
emulate real burn damage if you look at
a burn usually right around the lip of
the burn there's like a slightly lighter
color that's left there and that gives
the illusion of the edge being singed
and kind of melted which is i guess what
you would imagine for this kind of super
suit fabric for black noir suit the
super suits team deconstructed it into
panels allowing them to swap the
original pieces for pre-damaged ones and
then back again once filming ended and
look at the pieces of shrapnel and
melted bits in black noir suit following
a different explosion and then those
were sewn one by one onto the costume so
none of the damage was permanent
breakdown artists are a lot of things
they're scientists they're alchemists
they're detectives
[Music]
you